I'm honestly going to say, like, this JJ
guy might be legit. I hope he doesn't
come out like in a week on JJ's a fraud.
But, we put his strategy to the test
with no bias, no, um, expectations.
Definitely a promising strategy that if
you love 1-minute timeframe NQ scalping,
um, could be a strategy for you.
New guy in town that's, uh, one of my
trading friends shared with me, uh, JJ
Simon, somebody you've probably never
heard of before. He just started his
YouTube channel like a couple of weeks
ago, but pretty bold claims, uh, $1.2
million in payouts that he's claimed
he's made over the last, um, 12-13
months or so. Obviously, you know, it's
not fully verified on our end. I think
he has done a decent job so far of
showing like live logins. He showed like
a bunch of different bank accounts and
different things like that. I hope he
continues to show proof of the like
actual live logins and not, you know,
anything that can be edited or anything
like that, but, um, but yeah, he claims
to have made tons of payouts from all
kinds of different futures prop firms,
Topstep, uh, E8, Funded Next was, um,
that what that video he just recently
shared. And he trades a NQ, uh, 1-minute
scalping strategy. Uh, this guy's like
20 years old. I think he, uh, he said he
studied quantitative finance in, uh, in
in college and he's tried to, uh, apply
some of the things he's learned from
college to his trading. So, what is his
his strategy? I'll kind of break it
down, um, as usual, and I've got a
strategy PDF PDF for you guys that I
shared in the chats, um, as well as, um,
if you guys are watching the recording,
you guys can always, um, access this
from the link below. But, uh, yeah, I'm
going to go over his strategy.
I obviously, like, you know, for most of
these strategies we'll try to identify
like if there's a couple little tweaks
we can do to make it a little more
mechanical so that it's easier for you
guys to more consistently identify and
execute it. Um, you know, I'll I'll, you
know, mention a few things like that.
But, very high level, uh, before we get
into it, you know, just looking at his
chart visually, um, fair value theory is
his general strategy and he's identified
a few points in time where you can kind
of trade a early continuation away from
that price and expect to, you know, more
often than not mean revert back to that
price. And these references price can
often be like New York open at 9:30. Uh,
he also trades like a 2:00 p.m. like
kind of afternoon open, which is
interesting. Um, he also trades Asia
session, um, the open of Asia session.
And I think he's, uh, based in the US,
so he doesn't trade London. But, there's
several, uh, you know, periods you can
test. That's like that the basis of the
strategy and we'll get into like the
actual specifics of it in a second. So,
what is fair value theory? Let's, uh,
break down a couple educational
components first. Um, many of you should
be familiar with what is a market
structure break, um, or a break in
structure, um, but a couple
demonstrations. So, market structure
break is really if price is in a
downtrend and you see a close above a
previous, uh, kind of wick high. That's
a bullish market structure break. It
indicates a potential reversal in the
trend. Um, you might also hear a break
in structure, BOS, which is more of like
a trend continuation. So, like, whereas
this is a market structure break to the
upside, a break in structure would be
like the close below this low right
here, or we're continuing to the
downside, or a close below this low
here, we're continuing to the downside.
So, breaks in structures and market
structure breaks we use pretty
interchangeably, but all you all you got
to know is it's a kind of break of a
previous level with a close, not just a
wick past it.
Um, and so, uh, yeah, we'll get to you
all your comments in a second. Um, we'll
see if the strategy holds up. Obviously,
with most of these videos, uh,
especially these claims, like it's a
pretty bold claim. Uh, at the end of the
day, it's really important to validate
any of these strategies and see if it's
actually legit instead of just trusting
what everybody says, so that's exactly
what we're going to do today and see if
it's, um, actually profitable or, you
know, has promise or not. Um, the next
thing is like, uh, this concept of a
displacement candle. And in his, um,
kind of video, he talks about it being
like a large candle and kind of like a
decisive candle. Um, how decisive a
candle closes is something you can't
actually make a very mechanical
definition around. So, we can use this
like counter wick definition where
basically for a bullish candle that top
wick, if you measure from like the open
to that kind of the high, how much of
that, um, kind of range does the wick
make up? And like a decisive close you
could say, "Okay, I don't want that
counter wick to be more than 20% of that
range." That can indicate that that's a
really strong close. You're not seeing
much of a counter wick at all. Um, the
size of the candle is a little more
discretionary. That's something that's a
little harder to make a mechanical rule
set around. So, for my testing
specifically, I've tried to focus mostly
on like the decisiveness of the candle.
Um, obviously, if you tried to figure
out a way to incorporate size, too, that
could work. But, just to you show you
visually, like, this green candle right
here, this is a very decisive candle,
but it's not very strong. Uh, or sorry,
it's not very large. Like, it's
relatively small compared to these. This
one right here is kind of the best where
it's both decisive and large relative to
kind of the previous candles. But,
again, that's a little discretionary,
hard to,
you know, make a rule around what large
is or not. Um, same here. We have a a
fairly large candle, um, that also
closes decisively. So, these are kind of
displacement candle definitions and then
vice versa for shorts. Um,
this candle right here is a good example
of a non, um, decisive candle where
there was actually a pretty big counter
wick, more than 20%. So, this would like
not meet our criteria mechanical
criteria for like a decisive candle, um,
closing in our direction. Whereas this
one right here, um, did have a small
counter wick. Same thing. This candle,
this candle, like, very small counter
wicks that are less than 20% and again,
I kind of have some commentary about,
you know, this is a pretty big size,
this is a relatively small size, but
it's it's discretionary enough that I
think it's better it's going to be
better to focus on the decisiveness
versus the size, um, when testing.
Um, so, few strategy details and then
yeah, I'll get to you guys' questions.
If you guys have questions at any
points, uh, feel free to, um, ask. I'll,
you know, adjust everything I can.
Um, but,
we'll talk about the general parameters.
Obviously, this is NQ 1-minute
timeframe. He's 20 years old. He's
probably really good at first-person
shooters, would be my guess. And he's
trading 1-minute NQ timeframe, NQ
futures. Um, so, this is obviously a
futures specific strategy. Um, he trades
basically the market open, uh, through
about 11 to about 90 minutes after New
York open. And then for the the kind of
afternoon window, he'll start straight
charting at around 2:00 p.m. He didn't
he didn't specifically say how long he
trades. From my testing, I think it's
probably best to cut off around 3:00 if
you're trading that afternoon window.
And then again, you could also test the
first 90 minutes of Asia session, London
open. Um, you could also test other
assets to see if the same price theory
works on others, but he specifically
trades NQ, um, during a New York open,
New York p.m. And I think he does
sometimes trade Asia Asia. We'll talk a
little bit more that, uh, a little bit
later. So, again, fair value theory,
like I mentioned, um, his the whole
concept is if there's no new information
for the market to price in, it's most
likely like kind of already decided
what's fair value and, uh, it's price is
going to kind of like mean revert back
to that price. And he's found that the
9:30 open and the 2:00 p.m. New York
afternoon often act as fair value for
that.
Um, in terms of timing,
he generally looks for continuations
kind of away from the fair value the
first 10-15 minutes, um, after the open
and then look for mean reversions, uh,
back to that fair value the rest of the
trade window.
In terms of the entry model, it's pretty
sim- simple, um, not too complex.
Obviously, it's 1-minute timeframe, so
it's fast, but overall, it's it's pretty
simple. So, um, he says in his video he
does he will trade, um, displacements
only where like you're you only have
that displacement candle, um, but he
said the best combination is when it's
displacement plus a break in structure.
Um, so, I don't know if there's a great
example for the if you're upside here.
But, you can see the difference between
these candles. We have, uh, kind of
displacement that breaks structure here.
The second example is just the
displacement candle, no real structure
break. And the second one that worked
had a displacement plus break. So, I
decided to stick with the best. Okay?
So, we're going to use the break the,
uh, break of structure and decisive
candle for our kind of entry criteria,
either for the continu- continuation
away from the fair value price or coming
back to it, the market structure break
after the fact. Um, and so, you can see
kind of bullish and bearish examples
right here.
Um,
and then, yeah, somebody said they
thought it was the 9:29 candle. It's
basically market open. So, like, what
what price, um, opens, um, at, uh, when
you, you know, see the price. And he he
usually hides it highlights like the
first candle. Um, so, it's basically
that the what price opens, um, kind of
at market open.
And then, um, in terms of the stop loss
distance, this is another thing that,
um,
he didn't he he says he basically uses
like most often a 25 tick stop loss and
like a 38.5, um, tick tick profit for
1.5 R. Um, but he did mention there's
like more of maybe if it's more
volatile, then he'll do like a 50 tick
stop loss and 75 ticks. So, to give you
guys like a very mechanical way to
adjust your stop loss distance based on
how volatile price is, you can use the
average true range indicator, which is
kind of a a volatility indicator,
essentially. And, um, use that the level
of the ATR to determine like how big of
size your stop loss should be. So, if
it's over 20, like, price is really
moving, um, 50 tick stop loss is going
to be a good, um, stop loss distance.
And obviously, 1.5 R would be 75.
7 to 20 was kind of the range that I
was, uh, testing and playing around
with. Seems like a pretty good range,
um, that happens in most of the time for
that 25 tick stop loss, um, in the 38
and 1/2 tick tick profit. And then if
it's below 7 ATR, this is most often in
the New York p.m. session or probably
Asia session sometimes, too, if you're
trading that. Um, it's probably better
to tighten it up a little further and
use like a 16 and 1/2 versus 24.75. And
you might be wondering like where these
numbers come from. And, um, the
interesting way he obviously trades prop
firms, uh, futures prop firms, and
these, um, distances are specifically
designed so that if you have, um,
a, let's look at this first example. If
you have a pretty wide stop loss with 50
ticks, one contract on NQ is going to
equate to a $1,000 risk per trade.
So, the these levels are almost like
designed to work specifically with NQ
contract amounts.
So, one contract with a 50 tick stop
loss equates to $1,000 risk per trade.
Two contracts with a 25 tick equates to
$1,000 risk per trade, or three
contracts with a 16.5 tick stop loss.
1,000. So, like it's very easy to
adjust the quantity based on the stop
loss levels.
A few other rules we definitely need to
go over and then we'll look at a few
specific examples.
From my testing so far, and this is
something you could validate as well, it
may be best to avoid the first three
minutes after the 9:30 open.
A lot of people get pretty scared
trading market open anyways,
but it may actually not be worth trading
those first three minutes
if you're getting chopped up too often
and it's causing like too many losses.
Something you can test and validate
yourself, but from my testing so far
that seems like it may be best to wait
like the first three minutes before
taking these continuations.
Um,
he didn't mention it specifically in his
video, but looking at some some other
examples that I found, he often will
have like the VWAP on his chart as well,
so that could potentially be another
confluence to test and maybe find out
how he uses that to as a potential
confluence or not. I [snorts] didn't
personally test Asia session. I just
focused on New York session for my
testing so far, but if you're going to
trade Asia, he says he really only likes
to trade it if there's like a surge in
volume and volatility. Otherwise, he
doesn't like to trade it cuz it's
generally like pretty flat and choppy.
Same thing with second attempts. If you
he he in his video, he showed second
attempts pretty frequently. You know, I
had a loss here, took another try, had a
loss here, took another try. With FX
Replay, the great thing is you can use
tags to see Sorry, let's come back to
the PDF. You can use the tags to see
like is it worth taking the second
attempts or not. So, you can collect the
data and confirm if you should try it or
not.
Um,
he also mentioned you can trade news
with this strategy. The 8:30 a.m. red
folder news. You could trade mean
reversion back to the price before news.
Something else you could try again. I
didn't specifically test those. It's
something you guys can test with the FX
Replay like go to news feature if you
wanted.
Um,
and then let's see a couple other
things.
Oh, yeah. In his video, he shows not in
this specific example, it's probably a
little earlier.
Let me see if I can find where it is.
He shows like a few days of examples in
here.
I'm going to try and find what I'm which
one I want to reference.
He'll trade like
additional continuations after price
comes back. Um,
maybe this is a good one.
So, price has already moved away from
the and already kind of reverted back
and now he's taking subsequent
continuations and mean reversion. So,
in my testing, I tried to focus mostly
on like kind of this first move, the
initial move away and the move back.
But, you could also test and see if
these like kind of second moves are also
worth testing whether that's another
continuation or maybe it comes back up
to the other upside now and you can mean
revert back to it. So, you could also
test with additional
kind of trades after that initial move
away and mean reversion, but I just try
to focus on just that first move to keep
it simple so far
today. So, that's what that bullet
means.
Timing wise again, this is an
optimization opportunity I'm seeing from
some of the data that I'm starting to
test. It may be best to just stop
trading that second hour after the
window. So, maybe only the first 30
minutes of New York open and maybe only
the first hour in that in the afternoon
window. It's again an optimization. As
you get large sample size of data, you
can optimize and see like what the best
times are to trade.
And then I'd already mentioned you could
trade mean reversion either side of the
fair value. So, pretty simple checklist.
We're waiting waiting for for
continuations. We're waiting for either
a break of structure or market structure
break away from the fair value fair
value price
and looking for that combination of
displacement candle plus that break
for our entry. Or if price has already
moved away from fair value price, we're
looking for the same entry model back to
it essentially. Using the ATR to
determine our stop loss and just going
for a fixed 1.5 R no trade management.
So, couple examples and then we'll dive
right into FX Replay. So,
we have actually on this day both trades
played out. So, 9:30 market open
happened here and shortly after we had a
really nice market structure break to
the upside. Price had previously been
trending to the downside.
Our ATR was between 7 and 20, so I was
using a 25 tick stop loss here. Didn't
really get close to it in this case, but
moved up nicely to take profit after we
had a nice decisive candle plus the
break. And then as price came up a
little further, took a little while, we
eventually had a nice decisive candle to
the downside that also broke structure
here. So, we got our kind of two two
checklists for the for the trade. Same
stop loss, the ATR was still in in that
zone. So, same 25 tick stop loss. The
take profit was pretty much right back
to the fair value price and caught two
wins on this specific day.
Now we have an example from that
afternoon session. Similar price action.
Obviously, he's trading in the same
concept in pretty much all of these
situations. And again, we have a break
in structure here. I think price was
previously trending to the upside. So,
break of structure with that decisive
candle
gives us our entry. Stop loss
calculated based on the ATR. Ended up
catching a nice win and the same thing,
wait for that market structure break
with a decisive candle to return back
towards the fair value price. So, not
that complicated of a
entry model, but the timing of it and I
think the optimizations and obviously
like is it something realistic for you
to execute is probably the bigger
question that you need to ask. So, let's
have an FX Replay and do some
validation.
I've obviously been testing this on
myself.
So, I want to get have someone from the
chat give me a totally random point in
time in the last three years or
something. We're going to back test a
totally random point today.
To do Simon
at fair value theory
stream.
So, somebody in the chat give me like a
random day in the last like three years.
I'll pick like a random point in time
for this.
I'm going to load one of my previous
layouts.
Let's do this one.
March 4th, 2025. All right.
All right, March 4th. All right, and
then we'll see how far we get.
We'll we'll at least get through like,
you know, a few days.
>> [clears throat]
>> Nice, somebody shared their birthday.
All right.
So, I've got this layout that I set up
previously. I'm going to go ahead and
make a copy of it like I usually do. So,
I'll make a copy of this.
Make sure that I have a fresh layout.
So, this is stream.
Got to my layout named. I'll delete all
my previous drawing tools so we have a
totally fresh layout. And then
indicators that I have on the chart is
pretty simple. In this lower section
here, I have this ATR.
Which I I think you can type ATR. Yeah,
you just type ATR, average true range.
It's basically like kind of giving you
an indication of how volatile the price
action is or if it's smaller candles, so
it's going to be a smaller so the value
on the right kind of shows you the
current ATR value which we'll use for
our stop loss distance. Then I also have
like this volume overlay. We're not
specifically using it again. If you're
trading like Asia session, I think it's
going to be more important to like watch
for volume spike or something like that.
Otherwise, maybe pass on the session,
but that's you know, also something you
can play around with. So,
I've got couple different
sessions in here. I was testing some
other stuff this weekend. So, let's make
sure we update this specific for the
strategy. So, we want to be going to
9:30 for New York sessions. We don't
care about London specifically today.
And then I think there's like a New York
p.m. session that you can do 1400 down
here. So, we can save both of those out
to have access to both of them.
And we'll just jump right next to the
next 9:30 open.
And reset our chart.
So, 1-minute time frame NQ, we are good
to go.
And yeah, let's see what we have. So,
you can mark out the reference price
kind of at market open. He usually
shades like the first candle, but you
can just draw a line. Either one works.
And let's see if we can find
um,
some trades. So again, I'm going to I'm
going to personally be waiting like for
a couple minutes just cuz I'll show you
that at the end after some testing I've
done. It seems like it's best to wait.
So, I'm going to wait like a couple
minutes and then look for that decisive
candle to see if we can get a a break
either side. It's a very large candle.
It's not super decisive yet. I use this
fib retracement tool. Show you guys the
settings specifically. So, you're using
0, 2, and 1
for the fib retracement. You can use one
color. It's up to you if you want the
prices or not. I think it's easy, but
yeah, you can apply this fib level from
basically the open of the candle to the
low
and see like did it close decisively or
not. So, in this case we had too large
of a candle wick. So, this doesn't meet
our mechanical decisive candle
definition. Trade could work out, but
we're going to wait for a little more
clear criteria. This actually might be
might be one right here.
So, we do have a decisive candle now.
However, we haven't really broken
structure with this candle. You want to
see the break of the candle and the
decisive
decisive candle in the same
instance, whereas the break kind of
happened this first candle and now we're
in a decisive candle. So, we may just
need to wait for a market structure
or sorry, mean reversion in this case.
Again, very strong decisive candle, but
we do not have the structure to give us
the break. So, we may just kind of miss
this trade. The move happened
like in a couple of candles there.
Unfortunately, it just didn't meet our
specific criteria.
Just for for kicks, let's see the ATR on
this big candle we had down here was was
like 26. This would have been a pretty
large stop loss. And and a pro tip for
you guys, if you're if you're trading
the strategy, I really recommend setting
these um,
thresholds on the on the long and short
position tools and then save them as
templates. So, I already have like some
templates saved out. So, this 50 tick
stop loss, I can literally just right
click it, apply the template, and then
place the order. It's very quick to
apply the different stop loss distances.
So, this this If you would have taken
the less decisive break, this one would
have been a loss. Didn't really go to
our take profit.
This mean reversion might have might
have worked out, but again, we want to
wait for the highest probability setups
that have both the break and the
decisive candle on the same candle.
Okay, there's news. So, yeah.
It has done what he expected. It's kind
of pushed away, come back, pushed away,
come back. So, really the only play left
for this session,
you know, if you wanted to trade the
full, you know, 90 minutes after open is
a mean reversion back to this price. So,
we could see if it if it pushes up, we
could look for mean reversion, but looks
like it's really just hanging around
there. So, probably just better off
going to the afternoon session now.
Let's go to New York session.
And again, we'll mark out the opening
price
Kind of at the start of the session,
look for a continuation away from it. Um
the afternoon session from my testing
didn't matter as much if you waited a
few candles or not. So this like New
York market open is like crazy volatile.
Um but afternoon it seems like even if
it's like the first candle of the PM
session that seemed to was fine uh to
take if it met the criteria. So I think
we finally have a a trade here. So we
have a break in structure right here. We
took out this high.
We've been in an uptrend. We have formed
a swing high here. We pushed through it.
Now we're just going to verify the
decisive candle. Uh looks pretty
decisive to me but we can apply our fib
just to like double check.
So from the high to low it's very close
and this is where the price levels might
come into play. 2606.25
and it's literally right at that. So um
I'll let you guys decide if we want to
allow it to be exactly equal amount.
We'll go ahead and take it. Um I think
in the PDF I said it it can't be more
than. Um so we'll uh apply the and then
our what's our ATR? ATR is 23. So this
is also still pretty volatile. Um so
apply the 50 tick stop loss. Pretty big
stop loss. Um but we'll we've got our uh
levels applied. We'll place the order
here.
I've been using entry trigger one for
the continuations, entry trigger two for
the uh meaner versions. So we'll do that
and let me just let it play out. See
what happens. Nice. Got a win.
Um I'm going to make sure there's no
questions there. Somebody mentioned
there's also like a candle strength
indicator um that they've used in the
past. Um me honestly you guys you guys
could probably uh code now that we have
the custom indicators in FX Replay. Um
you could probably code this logic into
an indicator um and like I've I've in
the past you know tried a little bit of
coding and like you can sometimes use
like you know if you want to distinguish
the decisive candles or not like make
them have a white body or something like
that um to make it easily visibly to see
but for now with testing you can
obviously just use the fib retracement
uh tools and it's super easy. Um doesn't
take that long. You just just check it
out when you're testing. Okay. Might
have gone one too far.
So did we form a swing low here? That's
the only thing. I'm not really seeing
like a clear structural low. We've kind
of just like slowly melted up. We didn't
form like a decisive low here. Like if
you were really getting cute you could
say like we did kind of go up come down.
Um but I personally like visibly I'm not
seeing like a clear wick low. Um so this
probably doesn't quite meet the like eye
test for me. Um I'd rather see like a
clear market structure break.
And it might work out. It probably will
work out. But I want to try and like
visibly see. Okay. So this is like a
better definition but now we're pretty
we're already like pretty close to the
meaner version level. So in cases like
this I I was was really like not trying
to take the trade if we're already
pretty much like at our target. Like if
we're using um the 50 tick take profit
50 tick stop loss here like you'd have
to go all the way back through and it's
just like a little lower probability
than maybe if we were taking it up here.
Um
So this trade you know would have been a
little more in line with the fair value
theory. Um and I guess like if the take
profit level is like a little bit past
the fair value price it's probably okay.
He definitely has some examples where he
he does do that but if we're already
like super close to it I think these
trades are probably going to be a little
lower probability. We'll go ahead and
take it um just to see but I do think
like it's going to be better if you if
you're already kind of away from the
from the level a little bit. Um so we'll
say this is entry trigger two for our
meaner versions.
And I guess another way if if it comes
back to the fair value price you could
um go break even at that point.
Um yeah we got super close to our stop
loss and yeah got a loss there. So yeah
I do think um
in my testing I probably wouldn't have
taken this. I I took it today just to
show you guys kind of what the trades
would look like but overall um kind of
had the right idea didn't just didn't
quite come back to our fair value
theory. Um so very deci- very uh large
candle to the downside but not decisive
and it's also within that first kind of
3 minutes.
Also pretty large candle.
Um
So waiting a little bit here.
We are kind of coming back into the
price. Um so we could potentially see a
continue still see a continuation away.
Um we are kind of reverting around the
level but not seeing any specific This
is probably pretty close to decisive
candle but I can already tell it wasn't
quite. I've been testing this enough
that I could see it wasn't quite um a
decisive candle. There's a little bit
was a little bit too much of a counter
wick.
Um so now we're looking for mostly just
meaner versions. We want to see price
pushing away um from the zone either
either side and looking for a meaner
version.
So see if we can get some sort of
structure break
with a decisive candle
before our trading window ends. We've
still got a little bit time.
Okay. We're continuing to push up. No
strong candle. That's a very strong
decisive candle. Hasn't quite cleared
our structure yet. Um so again doesn't
quite meet the combined criteria that we
have um for the break plus the um this
decisive candle plus the break. Um but
does look like the right kind of candle
we want and we may just be after yeah
we've already kind of 30 minutes into
our I'm sorry we have 30 minutes left.
Um we could test.
So we still have a little bit time we
could look for a meaner version if it
meets the criteria.
You can see here like even though we had
the the kind of strong displacement
candle since there wasn't a structure
break it didn't work out. Um so that's
why the combination of the two is going
to be higher probability for sure. Uh so
this is probably good enough. Um it's
definitely um not as good as like this
strong candle here. Um but if we do have
a really decisive candle here and it did
form the break in structure. We have now
closed below this previous structure
level. So I think this is probably good
enough. Um our ATR at this point is
still 26. Um so we're still going to
stick with the 50 tick. Um we're
probably going to be 50 ticks alive if
this is 2025.
Um
So we'll go for this one uh with entry
trigger two
for our meaner versions. Um again you
could use additional tags for other
confluences or anything else you want.
No trade management. Just simply letting
it play out. Front ran our tick profit
by two
>> [laughter]
>> couple ticks.
And eventually got TP. Nice. Um so that
would have been a pretty emotional
roller coaster if you were taking that
one but eventually played out. He
doesn't do any trade management as far
as I know. He just lets it play out um
win or loss. Um somebody asked a
specific question what about the large
green candle on this uh this day? Uh
large green candle at 10 to 10:05
I think they said. Um 10:05 right here.
Maybe right here. Um Okay. One of these
times. So there's a large green candle
right here and this is where um I'd
mentioned in the PDF um specifically
you could take additional continuations
after price returns to fair value. Um
but you'd probably want to use a
separate tag. So like when I've been
testing
he he said specifically in his video he
really tries to look for um
continuations the first like 10 minutes
or so. Um so this is like you know
34 33 minutes after open. It's it's
pretty you know it's it's a it's
definitely after the period that he
started. Um so you could you could test
these and see like okay if it's come
back to the zone and we see a
continuation maybe I use entry trigger
three for those like kind of second move
continuations or something like that.
And you can collect data to see like are
those worth taking or is that first move
really like the best thing to take? Same
thing like we're taking it we took a
meaner version short here but say you
were in the session we saw this meaner
version short and you saw like uh an
opportunity for a meaner version long
like still in your session you could
also take these kind of second move
meaner versions and see if those are
worth taking too. So recommend using
different tags um and see
as we usually do we'll mark out the
reference price so it's easy to see
visually.
You could probably code an indicator to
do that too but it's not that hard to
just draw a line.
Um so nice decisive candle. Nice
structure break. Let's see if it's
decisive or not.
Yep. No the counter wick is less than
20% so we got everything we need here
for a continuation.
What's our ATR? ATR is 22 still so still
going with the 50 tick
stop loss. Um so we'll take this one
with entry trigger one.
Place the order.
Let's see what we got here.
Come chop around a bit. Getting closer
to take profit. Nice win.
So now uh we can look for the meaner
version back. Um we're looking for the
same same price signature. The break
with the strong decisive candle which we
have right there.
Check our ATR quickly. It's 20.25 so
it's just over the 20 threshold. If it's
under 20 then we would drop it um to the
25 tick but we'll stick with our 50
tick. Um can try and look for a move
back to the level.
Uh we'll say this is entry trigger two
for our meaner versions.
And we'll see what we got in this case.
Chopped around a little bit and nice win
again. We're on a nice little win
streak. I will say like um the thing
that I like about this strategy that I
haven't seen in a lot of the strategies
I test is it's it's not going for the
most precision in terms of stop loss
that other strategies have where you'll
use the recent structural low or maybe
even like to get a little more risk
reward you use like the body low. Um
he's not as concerned about being so
precise with getting the exact right
entry or the exact right stop loss. He's
just like trying to say okay I think in
general price is going to go this way so
as long as I give myself enough wiggle
room to to catch that move then I
hopefully I'll be right more than I'm
wrong. Um so that's like kind of the the
thing I do like about these like um ATR
based stop losses. It's it's something
you could play around with other
strategies too if you keep getting
barely stopped out on the move when you
generally have the right idea. It may be
better to use a little more general um
kind of numbers based um stop loss
instead of always using structure or
something like that.
Um
And then yeah it's obviously going to be
hard like hard to execute in a live
market for sure. Um but again um outside
of the like New York open trades where
you do tend to have to be pretty quick.
Like price often you know does give you
a little bit of time to execute this.
Like even though it entered here you had
like seven whole minutes to enter at
this price. Um obviously sometimes it's
going to go immediately and you'll just
like you might miss it. Um but even here
you had a couple couple other tries. So
even if you know by the time you see it
it's too late you could still see if you
can catch like a limit order at the end
at the same price before it takes
profit. I bet you'd still they'll to
catch a good amount of the trades Even
if you couldn't execute like a right at
the exact um point that it triggers.
So this is again where you could
potentially track
a kind of second move continuation super
strong candle.
Definitely broke a lot of of structure
right here.
Decent chance that it has continuation.
I'm not going to specifically record it
because I haven't been recording these
testing.
So I just don't really have the data on
them, but this is definitely something
if you want to increase the trade
frequency even more, you could also test
these kind of second move continuations
and mean reversions.
Does look like it would moved a little
bit, but probably would have cut a loss
off that one. The The candle is like
already too large.
So it's probably good enough. Again, I
don't want to trade past the you know
first hour of the afternoon session. We
kind of already got two wins. So
probably you should probably be happy
with that. So
it is specific criteria that you need
the break and the decisive candle on the
same candle.
We didn't have the decisiveness on this
candle. We don't technically have a
break on this candle. So this move might
work out, but you know
also might not have worked out. So
waiting for those specific criteria to
be met probably going to improve
your probability over time. But yeah,
the fair fair value theory played out.
It moved away, came back to it. Now
we're moving back up. We can still look
for a mean reversion for for a little
while. It's a really good candle. Didn't
quite break our structure yet though.
That doesn't quite meet our criteria.
This one might be good enough. Let's see
if it's decisive. Pretty sure it is.
20 at 152. Yeah, we're definitely below
that level we needed for the
decisiveness. So what's our ATR at? We
are at 35 ATR man. This is super
volatile.
This might be getting close to when the
tariff stuff was happening last year.
Can't remember. But yeah, definitely 50
tick stop loss kind of coincides with
this candle high. And let's see if we
can catch a mean reversion back to
our entry with entry trigger two.
We got close to our take profits.
Nice win. So yeah, the
stop loss distances have been working
great. There's been quite a few trades
where we did come into a little bit of
drawdown, but because we were adjusting
the stop appropriately for the
volatility, we were able to kind of
you know survive and and wait for a win.
So really happy with that. And now we
can go to our PM session.
New York PM session.
Okay, there we go. That's exactly what
we want. Now let's just see if it's like
too close to the level.
Our ATR is 24 still. So we're still
using our
50 tick stop loss.
And again, just to show you guys how you
can adjust that.
I have this template for 50 ticks, but
if I wanted to use 25, I have this
template. I can easily like very quickly
modify like the levels. It's super fast.
And if you have these templates saved,
you just apply the template and then
place the order. It's super quick to
apply these different stop loss
thresholds depending on
what you need. So again, this is a
example where like the take profit is
quite a bit of ways beyond the fair
value level. So either you would
probably want to pass on this or I don't
know. Another option you have is if it
taps if it taps the fair value price,
maybe at least go break even at that
point. So maybe that's what we'll try
this time to at least make sure it
doesn't like come back on us if it cuz I
think he said like it's pretty random
after it comes back to the fair value
levels. This is entry trigger two for a
mean reversion.
We'll pull out our fair value price
again just a little bit further.
So we did tap it like to the tick pretty
much and came back. So like I said,
maybe we'll go break even here. But
yeah, the fact that our take profit was
kind of beyond the fair value price just
made this one a little lower probability
I think.
So it's good to the next session. Again,
this is why we're trying to avoid the
first few minutes of New York open
because it can be super volatile. Really
nice
break candle here, but probably not
decisive enough.
We would need 830.5
and it's 820. Actually this is.
Yeah, it was decisive enough. I didn't
think it was, but it did pass the level.
So we can use
our short here for continuation. And we
finally have an ATR below 20. Barely.
19.7.
So this is where we could use the 25
tick stop loss. It looks a little tight
like obviously compared to the candle.
This is maybe a little higher
probability to stop us out. We'll see
what happens this one.
Actually worked out. So I thought it was
going to be 50/50
cuz we didn't have a lot of room for it
to come back, but just going for that
one and a half hour,
we were able to catch it catch it for a
nice win.
And then yeah, not probably not going to
have a whole opportunity for mean
reversion. It happened like very quick.
And again, this potentially could have
been an entry for us, but at that point
ATR is back over
20. So yeah, our take profit is like way
on the other side now of the ATR.
So it's going to be probably a little
lower probability. But we can see if it
pushes away either side and see if we
get a mean reversion
after the fact.
So let's see if we can get a mean
reversion that meets our criteria.
Looking for a structural break plus the
decisive candle.
Playing forward a little bit. I might
have missed one. Let's see.
So we had a little little baby swing
high right here and a break above it. I
don't know if this is decisive enough.
Let's measure it. So the level is
19732.5.
So it did not quite. It was like one
point off.
And so I'm basically like looking at the
price level on the 0.2 to see like okay,
price needed to close at or above this
level. And then like for the current
candle price, you can see what the price
is. So you can basically compare those
and see
pretty quickly if it's decisive or not.
Hopefully that's helpful. Or obviously
make an indicator for it.
So it didn't quite meet the criteria
there. We're still continuing to wait
for the specific criteria we need.
Strong candle not quite decisive enough
I can tell.
We may be getting We still got like 30
minutes I guess. So again, I was seeing
a little lower probability after the
first 30 minutes, but
we can still trade through through 11
cuz he says he'll generally trade like
the first 90 minutes after open.
Still just kind of melting down.
We are pretty far away from our price
theory. And I guess like other thing
that I do want to mention too,
I've simplified his strategy a lot, but
like you'll see in his video like he's
looking up like Trump tweets and things
like that to see like is there new
information that validates this move?
Like I don't know. Maybe something came
out and the market does not like it. And
you know, maybe we don't have it as like
a standard red folder event or something
like that, but in real time maybe there
was actually something that validated
like okay, this is like a a reasonable
move because of this new information the
market didn't like.
So that's something that you have more
access to when live trading and
backtesting. I think it's something
better to focus on the data that you do
have consistently, which is obviously
time and price and like expected news.
But but obviously like in a live
environment with a little more
discretion, I think he's able to
have a little more context and draw
additional like fair value levels beyond
just these opening prices. He'll you'll
often see in some of his videos where
he'll draw like kind of like what seem
like almost like random consolidations
where he'll like see okay, this is like
where the market had now kind of agreed
that the price fair value was kind of
around this level.
So there are additional
fair value levels you could trade as
well, but you would probably need a
little bit more insights on how exactly
he does that. I think
it's fine to just stick to these opens.
It's it works well enough it seems.
Okay, maybe we're we're getting pretty
close to the end of the hour. So far
just no trades this day. So let's look
at the analytics. Like I said, this is
going to be above average. Like I will
show you guys the other sessions I
tested. It is not this high of a win
rate, but thank you for whoever
suggested
March of 2025 cuz yeah, this strategy
crushed during the period we tested. But
obviously it's only eight trades.
So this is like another important thing.
Just as important as if you test a
strategy for 10 trades and it sucks.
If you test a strategy for 10 trades and
it's amazing, it doesn't guarantee that
it's going to do well over a large
sample size. You need to make sure to
validate with a proper sample size. So I
will show you guys some periods that
I've tested to give a little more
context. So I tested 2020 February of
this year cuz obviously he's been
trading this pretty recently. So I
wanted to see how it did
earlier this year. So let's see if I can
filter
on that. I think I tried to name it like
February 2026 or something like that.
So I tested 43 trades over that period.
And in the month of February I was able
to get 19R.
Actually this is this is only like half
of February. So this is
very good. You know, 19R in
You know, you're obviously you're
trading a lot. There's quite a bit of
chart time.
And obviously one minute charts like
drive some people crazy. So you have to
be have the
aptitude and desire to do it. But higher
frequency with a lower time frame. 58%
win rate performed very very well during
this period this recent period that I
tested. Let's jump around. What other
periods I test? I tested this like
pretty strict uptrend here from like
April of
2025 like late April 2025 to like early
May. So
let's come back to the replay. Filter on
that session.
If I grab it here, this would have been
uptrend probably.
Upholding market.
Okay. And
started out of definitely a little
flatter.
For for a while we were having around
like you know, plus or minus 5R with a
little bit of drawdown. Eventually
caught a little steam towards the the
later half of it. And so also
profitable. 56% win rate. I think it's a
much more reasonable compared to like
85% win rate or something like that. But
that's a solid profit factor. Like 1.93
profit factor is really good.
And then last period I tested, I think I
wanted to yeah, super super choppy
market. So I tried to find like the
rangiest conditions I could find. This
is like April of 2023 through
April yeah, basically April of 2023.
And I don't even know if he's tested
this far back. I think he's most of his
testing has been the last two years. So
this would have been kind of ranging
market conditions. So, I'll filter on
those real quick.
Ranging markets.
Not as good.
Um,
it was, you know, I I think most
strategy Even with the mean reversion,
you probably the mean reversions were
okay here. Um, but overall, it was still
a little bit worse in this condition. I
think most strategies are probably not
going to trade well when you got barcode
price action. Um,
but uh to give you guys I've jumped
around a few different market conditions
and we have like a really good sample
size for this. I want to show you guys.
So, now if we go to our recent session,
I've created a strategy for this and all
these sessions that I've traded, I'm
going to link up to this specific
strategy.
Um, so we can look at all the analytics
together and get some really good
insights. So, JJ Fair Value Theory.
If you tie your sessions to the
strategy, then you can filter the
strategy um itself either by going to
the analytics
and then
filtering, you don't need the sessions
anymore, but if you look for
the specific strategy,
you can filter it that way. Or often
what I'll do um
is just go to the strategies page.
I have to like search for it cuz I have
so many of them now.
But you could also just click the
analytics from the strategies page and
get it a little quicker. Um, so overall,
uh testing that we have, uh yeah, a lot
of profit in two weeks, but also a lot
of chart time and probably a lot of gray
hairs from trading one minute charts.
So, if it's for you, then great, but
it's definitely not for everyone. Um,
but yeah, let's talk about what we have.
So, 158 trades. Um, you're welcome. I
was curious and like I thought in
specifically in his case since he is
like such a new trader, um you know,
even we've had other traders that I've
tested, Trader Cain, um
Tom Trades, Scarface, who like have been
like around a little bit longer and are
making these claims. This guy like made
his YouTube channel like two weeks ago.
So, I really wanted to spend some time
and actually validate and help you guys
like make sure you're not wasting your
time. Um, so I was curious and it was it
was fast enough to test. Um, but I, you
know, jumped down and did 158 trades for
you guys, so you're welcome. Um, I still
encourage you you to test this yourself
obviously, but over all the period we
tested, 54% win rates,
1.76 profit factor. Honestly very solid.
Um, we can look at the different um tags
that we have and then see how they how
they varied um by time frame. So, and
the continuations have slightly higher
win rate, which is very common.
Continuations generally tend to be a
little higher probability over two
profit factor.
Max win streak of eight, max loss streak
of five. Um, we had more buys than sells
in the period.
Um,
and then yeah, pretty similar results
between the AM session and PM session.
Probably slightly higher win rate in the
PM session, it looks like, um but still
profitable in in the performance
session. Uh performance by day, um
Tuesdays, Wednesdays seems a little
lower, but again, this is something that
as you get, I mean, this is a pretty
good sample size, but
over 200 trades, you would probably
going to say like definitively, okay, if
I take out Tuesdays and Wednesdays, I'll
be able to pretty, you know,
significantly improve my results. Um,
and again, looking at performance by
month, anywhere between um sorry.
Anywhere between like 2% uh sorry, 2R
and 15R just trading the continuations.
Um,
we can also look at the risk reward
simulator. I'll run that real quick
before we pivot over to the mean
reversions. And yeah, 1.5 is optimal um
for this strategy the the way we traded
it. It doesn't say that any other risk
reward level is going to drastically
improve our results. I mean, we could
get really granular if we wanted and see
like, okay, what about 1.4R or what
about uh 1.6R?
Really close and see, okay, there you
go. 1.6R is slightly better. So, if you
want to get a little bit more out of the
edge, um you maybe you can go 1.6R
instead of
uh just 1.5. And then obviously, same
thing with other optimizations. I'm sure
there were some trades where it was
worth, you know, trying to trail if
there's trend line liquidity or
something like that. So, you could
obviously play around with additional
optimizations like that, too. But risk
reward simulator shows a little bit of
insights. Maybe we can get a little bit
more of the continuations by going for
1.6R instead of 1.5.
Um,
and then now let's look at the entry
trigger two. Um, cuz that's going to be
the mean reversions and see what
insights we can have from that. So,
little lower win rate, 59 or 49% win
rate. Still 15R over the period, 1.46
profit factor, still not quite as good,
but I definitely think there's some good
optimization opportunities with this.
Um, obviously we had a little bit of a
larger loss streak with the lower win
rates.
But um
this is what I wanted to show you guys.
So, from the testing that I've done,
it seems like um you may not want to
take mean reversions if they happen
after the first 30 minutes of New York
open, which means basically only take
mean reversions if they happen within
that first 30 minutes of open. You know,
you've you've taken the continuation or
maybe there wasn't a continuation, but
price has at least moved away um from
the level and you're taking kind of an
earlier reversion back to the level cuz
it seems like later on um they are a
little lower probability. Again, I
didn't personally take those like second
mover versions. Um, so if you added
those to the mix, like um like this one
for example, that's kind of the second
mover version.
Maybe if you added more of these, it
would maybe offset and improve that
second hour window or whatever, but for
my testing, I was mostly focused on kind
of that first move.
So, just some context there. If you if
you're testing it like I had, then you
probably want to just stick to the first
30 minutes. And then same thing, it
seems like the trades there's there's
only eight trades, so not super
material, but you probably only only
want to trade mean reversions the first
hour
of that PM window and just don't worry
about trading the last um last like I
guess 3:00 p.m. to 4:00 p.m. of New York
session. Performance by day, maybe drop
Wednesdays. Um, seems like Wednesdays do
not do well and maybe increase risk
Fridays. Again, these are I have decent
sample size here. This is 67 trades.
This would be better way better with
like 2 300 trades.
Um, but if you get large sample size,
you can get some good insights to see,
okay, I need to just drop Wednesdays and
maybe I go I risk 2R instead of 1R um
for for Fridays if they're doing it in
90% win rates. Um, same thing
with performance by month. A little
lower on these. Definitely most of our
returns came from the continuations.
Just looking at this these monthly
performances, we got 15R here versus
entry trigger one. Um,
I think it was like 40R if I remember.
Um, I'm pretty sure it's like 40R. But I
want to look at the risk reward
simulator for these as well.
So,
interesting.
Um, if you are ex- if you can accept a
27% win rate, um
it seems like holding the mean reversion
a little better. Um, could improve your
results a little bit.
Um, I usually don't recommend people go
for a 27% win rate strategy, so I would
say probably this probably gives you an
idea that in certain occasions, there
are reasons to like trail the stop loss.
Um,
you know, if you have I'm trying to see
if I can come up with a quick example
right here. Um, like in this specific
this is a is a good example. Like this
trade right here kind of just melted
straight down. There weren't like there
were there weren't highs. There wasn't
trend line liquidity in the sense that
um
there weren't like additional levels
that could propel price further very
easily. Instead, you were kind of coming
into these imbalances that could reject
down. So, like a trade like this, you
probably wouldn't want to um to try and
hold for longer, but let me see if I can
find uh the same example. We'll go down
here.
If you were trading a mean reversion
down here, um you see here we have some
kind of trend line liquidity from these
kind of stacked highs along the way. So,
it's maybe a little better um to to
trail the stop. So, giving you guys some
ideas that your trailing stop loss
application for optimizations doesn't
have to be every trade. You could
identify um specific conditions that are
more con- you know, condoning on holding
holding the trade longer and seeing it
if you hold certain trades longer, you
could potentially improve results um
based on this. Um, that's probably what
I would try and do so that instead of
just accepting 27% win rate, maybe you
can get somewhere in between there, um
but improve your your average risk
reward. Um, but I think even if we just
excluded uh those
um the times that we that we saw, um
we'll see pretty good results. Like I in
fact did that.
So, I took my FX Replay export, which
you can do at the top here, and
literally just dumped it into Excel real
quick. I was looking at continuations
first. And to show you guys um why I
found like the first three minutes were
bad. So, you could filter these like by
time. So, this is this is just the FX
Replay export and then I added this um
formula mod of the the time.
And then you just put a comma one. It
just gives you like the time and you
just format it as a time. So, you can
get the specific time for the trades.
And then if I just literally filter on
the first like three minutes, uh we made
like 40R um across all these, I'm pretty
sure. Where's the P&L right here? 36R.
Over these and then this is like the
testing I did before. It doesn't include
the most recent data.
But if we filter just the first three
minutes,
uh we've only made 2R um in that and
there's there's like what it what is
this like?
Uh
am I I'm not seeing the count here.
Let's see the count. 28 trades, you're
only making 2R. Um, so it's going to be
a super low win rates. Um, I don't know
if I counted it, probably like 40 40%
win rate something like that. Um, all
this to say like it it may be worth
waiting like three minutes after open
and not taking those first first few
candle continuations cuz they do seem
like they're a little lower probability
based on that. And then
So, if we if we remove these trades and
then if we take out those
um kind of bad windows for our entry
trigger two, which were basically the uh
10:00 to 11:00 window and the the 3:00
to 4:00 p.m. window. Um, so if you do a
few simple optimizations just like kind
of using the analytics, uh where is
this? Right up here.
Um, which I've done here. I've kind of
combined everything.
We instead of having and I'll look at
our I'll compare like our overall
analytics
without this new session. So, let me
just I'll just do a little comparison
for you guys.
So, this is all the testing I did
before. Um, hunt still 150 trades, 46R,
uh 52% win rate, 1.66 profit factor. And
then after I removed
a few of those um I removed those first
three minutes. I removed the 10 and 11
hour versions. I removed the 3 to 4 p.m.
hour versions. Now we have a 2.46 profit
factor with a 62% win rate. So, very
simple optimization. No new rules or
whatsoever. Just literally like using
the time.
Um,
date your data um, from the analytics to
optimize. So,
um,
I'm honestly going to say like this JJ
guy might be legit. Um, I hope he
doesn't come out like in a week on JJ's
a fraud.
>> [laughter]
>> Um, but we put his strategy to the test
with no bias, no um, expectations. Um,
made a little bit more of of mechanical
rule set so you could consistently
identify and execute it.
Um, so, you know, slightly different
than maybe the video he showed. Um,
being a little more specific with the
combination of criteria that we had. But
honestly, yeah, this is a super solid
um,
data set that we have so far. Definitely
a
promising strategy that if you love
1-minute time frame NQ scalping, um,
could be a strategy for you. And check
it out.
Um,
if you guys want more information about
um, FX Replays uh, Discord. Um, it's
also linked in all of the YouTube
videos. Um, or I'll probably on the
website if you scroll down to the
bottom. Um, there's a Discord icon.
Um, so if you want to, you know, see if
other people are checking uh, this
strategy other strategies, feel free to
hop in the Discord. Um, ask questions. I
usually am answering answering questions
and also other traders. Um, so you guys
can can hop in there. Totally free. And
then obviously, um, FX Replays going to
be the best way to for you guys to
actually validate these strategies
yourself instead of just trusting
anybody, myself included, that um, that
it does well. But yeah, the period we
tested today obviously crushed. But I'm
sure there's also periods that you have
30% win rates. Um, so, um, yeah. We'll
see if uh, he comes out with more
content. But does seem like a promising
NQ scalping strategy for those of you
that want to check that out. So, but
with that, we'll wrap it up. Hope you
guys have a great rest of your week and
I'll see you later everyone. Bye.